this is the face of the resistance young
angry and back on the streets of Hong
Kong millions have marched against a
planned extradition bill but it's mainly
the youth who've clashed with police
determined to fight but terrified of
being identified by the powers they're
challenging I use cash to pay everything
I'm afraid of the Chinese government I
just don't trust them the morning began
with road blocks the start of promised
disruption after the government missed a
deadline to meet their demands police
headquarters were quickly surrounded
[Applause]
stranded officers imprisoned in their
own van politicians and the
demonstrators can't try to negotiate but
the power of perceived police brutality
we as legislators we certainly don't
want to see any more bloodshed or any
major confrontation happen especially to
our young but I think it is not for us
to control the crowd
after three hours a rescue mission was
launched a human shield allowed the man
to be back
[Applause]
but anger flared as the protesters but
it didn't come alter of the day they
chanted release but no arrested
protesters which free as their list of
demands lengthens their resolve
also pardons oh we track nor we treat
what does it mean you've come and
rechecked the bill that in weekend
retreat and we came back to the normal
life
and if that doesn't happen your keeper I
think we will keep fighting Hong Kong as
we'll keep fighting with this fight the
authorities have lost a generation they
don't trust the government they don't
trust the police and the longer the
standoff continues the deeper the
divisions Siobhan Robbins Sky News Hong
Kong